So what are the TA's responsibilities?
We've developed a TA's Creed, which you should know if you're going to be a TA.
First, you need to be responsible.
If there's a problem you need to pass it up through the chain of command so that it can
be addressed rather than forgotten.
Also you need to be respectful to the students who are struggling away with the sometimes
difficult and challenging material.
A student might be struggling with something you find easy, but its unhelpful to imply
that things "should be easy" or that a student "should know" something.
You need to have empathy for the different learning journey that every student is on.
Further, you'll need to be relevant, informative and resourceful.
This means staying "on topic".
Students will get stuck in this real-world software; and they'll get stuck down all different
sorts of alleyways to do with version issues and libraries and so on.
You'll need to be resourceful think on your feet, and get the right sorts of information
to the right people at the right time.
One of the key things really is to be actively engaged with the courseware.
Particularly if you took the 169 course some time ago then you may not have the assignments
and the aspects of it in the forefront of your mind.
Ideally you need to be working through the courseware with the students so that you've
looked at the assignment and just completed it, i.e. the one they've been working on that
week.
You also need to be a facilitator.
Which means that rather than just solving problems, you need to help other people solve
their own problems - and we'll talk more about this as we go on in this next section.
In terms of supporting students what we really want is the students to become more and more
independent of the TA's and the instructors and so on.
We want the students to become independent learners.
As much as possible we would like to help them discover the answers by themselves.
Rather than just saying: "this is how you do it, and then you do this, and then you
do this", we need to provide a scaffolding.
A scaffolding that is about helping them learn to discover the answers by themselves.
We'll get into that in more detail in a minute.
Another key thing is helping them get past needless roadblocks to learning.
For example say the student is stuck because of a version issue.
There is a judgement call here about whether we just give the answer to that particular
fix that so that we can focus on a higher-level software engineering issue ...
Or is it actually that this versioning or library issue is something that they could
solve by themselves through a process of exploration?
And making the right decision is tricky, and requires intuition that you will need to develop
over time.
It's good to be aware that there are two sides to every problem. Some may just need to be fixed
if the learner is too stressed, and if the problem is not related to the current learning
objective.
However other problems can be used as a springboard for learning, and helping a student become
an independent learner.
Naturally providing correct, relevant, and clear information is absolutely essential.
Furthermore we also want to maintain a culture of collaboration, because a positive process
of collaboration is fun and helps people learn.
So it's essential that we support the students in helping each other, by encouraging students
talking to each other about challenges and so on.
We definitely want to get as much of that as we possibly can.
So there's a number of different forums where students will be communicating with each other.
We've got an asynchronous bulletin board in the form ofthe edX forum.
We've also got live realtime chat, that is embedded into the HTML of the site - that's
using Gitter: a GitHub-based chat client.
The key thing in any of these forums is to maintain civility, we're all professionals,
we're all adults.
There's no reason not be polite to each other.
We're all trying to work together to try and improve our knowledge and understanding of
all the materials.
So let's be civil.
We also suggest cutting off unproductive discussions.
That's again a judgement call about what is a productive or unproductive discussion.
I think a light touch is generally the way to go but if things really are descending
into less than civil tones or getting widely off topic them that's a good time to try to
wrap that discussion up.
A warning sign is when two parties are just repeatedly saying the same thing over and
over, or the debate is going far beyond the sensible "agree to disagree" end point.
Also important is being helpful without just giving the complete solution.
For example someone could say "I'm stuck on homework two" and you say could right "Ah
here is the entire solution for homework two" which is arguably "helpful" from one point
of view but it's not necessarily helping the student master the material.
So try and and be helpful without giving away the solution.
It's also valuable to keep the different threads and the discussions on-topic.
Really try and make all the forums and the chats a place that students can enjoy going
to for discussing the class topics.
We all want to have fun, so that's key :-)
Now let's talk about this scaffolding concept which you may or may not be familiar with.
There's this idea of instructional scaffolding which as I've alluded to already, is about
giving them more "temporary" support, and not just giving a complete solution.
Just sort of helping them a little bit.
A trivial example might be that, say you were learning a new language and you're trying
to remember the translation of a word and somebody gives you the first letter of the
word, instead of the whole word.
There's evidence to show that if you can then correctly recall the answer, that this partial
"scaffolding" will help you recall the same word yourself more easily next time around.
So that intervention is a "scaffold".
You're not telling the learner the complete answer or walking them step-by-step through
the task.
You're helping them figure out how to do the task on their own.
It's about rather than just "give an answer" to what the students ask for; it's about helping
them think for themselves by asking questions.
The other implication of it being scaffolding is also that it can be gradually removed over
time.
So as time goes by so you can gradually give less support.
You don't necessarily have to be involved personally in removing that support.
Your ongoing involvement with an individual learner will depend on the extent to which
you re-interact with different students as the course goes on and in a course as large
as this maybe you won't interact with the same student again, but then again ...
However, the idea of the scaffolding is at least it's there for support at the beginning
and then ultimately by the time the students graduate the course they don't need that scaffolding
anymore and they can get on by themselves.
I want to give a quick example with Ruby.
Over here I've got the command line and this is sort of a trivial example here but let's
say that we've defined some method in Ruby like so
And a student has unwittingly made a call to that method like this
and they're saying "hey look, I'm getting an error, I don't know what's going on"
Now if you know Ruby reasonably well this will seem pretty simple and you might be tempted
to say: "oh yes I know exactly what the problem is"
And you might be tempted to just to tell the student the fix. You could just say "oh right you
need to redefine the method with some arguments" and you could just give them the solution.
A more scaffold-based approach would be to start asking some questions like: "okay so
... what are you actually trying to achieve here, what's the high-level goal?" which might
seem odd in this simple example, but becomes more important as things get complex.
And then you say "so does any part of the error message make sense to you?"
And depending on what they say you direct them to the part of the error message that
says "ArgumentError: wrong number of arguments" and ask "does that mean anything to you?"
So rather than saying explicitly "you need to add arguments to your method definition",
you can be asking if the student knows what an argument is.
Or better yet, waiting for them to ask you what an argument is.
Maybe the student has already carefully read the error message and they've just no idea
what arguments are.
So then you can say "well arguments are things that you pass to a method" and maybe show
some examples and then say "there's the wrong number of them in this case".
As before this is a judgment call about at what point to intervene with what question
or information.
How much scaffolding should we give?
I mean it can be frustrating for the student if it seems like you're asking too many questions.
It is something that you have to build up an intuition for over time.
Note that this is also the same sort of support that a senior developer might give to a junior
developer in order to help them grow as a developer.
Although in a project with a paying client you've got to balance what's best for learning
against what's best for delivering the product on time.
Anyhow, you can also read lots of materials online.
We'll post some links for other reading on this topic on instructional scaffolding.
In summary, rather than just providing answers you want to help pose questions to the learner
that allows them to discover the solution in their own way.
Error messages in a new language can seem very intimidating and we want to help students
gain confidence in navigating them.
So that next time they have a better chance of solving a similar, or even a more difficult,
problem without any support.
Also you'll need to know how to connect with the team and there's certain critical things
to do.
Such as checking into and out-of the AV102 Slack chat.
We have a chat room in Slack so as you come online (and you should post and let us know
"I'm going to be checking the forums" or "I'm going to be hanging out in the Gitter chat")
So that you check in and when you've finished answering student questions or what have you, then you
check out in the Slack chat saying "I'm finishing up for now"
This is really all about announcing that you're on-duty because we'll have 200+ TAs and if
all them are on duty in the same two hour period then that's not a very effective way
of serving the many thousands of students.
So we want to have a mechanism whereby we let each other know when we're working so
that as we're checking in we can tell if lots of other people are already active in the
forums and chat.
And if they are you can say to yourself "Oh I'll come back in a couple hours instead and
try and contribute then"
You'll also want to mention in the AV102 Slack chat when you're addressing a students' question,
by posting a link to that question.
That will help avoid many TAs trying to answer the same question at the same time independently;
and draw them together in slack to collaborate on an answer if necessary.
Another thing that we're keen for you to do is to encourage the students to pair program
with each other.
As in previous versions of the course we have a framework for students to do pair programming
together.
One of the key bits of feedback that we've received is that it's sometimes difficult
for students to get themselves started.
So we're really keen to have TA's help students get started with pair programming:
Starting a session, for example, if you've got too many students in the same session
you might encourage them to split off into pairs who are working on the same parts of
the same homeworks and so on.
Also you should ensure that they aren't just posting complete solutions, or taking copies
of solutions if they've just joined the end of a pairing session.
One of the best ways you can help here is ensuring that you've done as much pair programming
yourself as possible, and sharing tips on what you find helps remote pairing work well
for you.
Of course one of the most critical things is to be engaged.
I think if you really want to help students you probably want to actually re-do the assignments
the week before the students do them; ideally pairing on them if at all possible :-)
I will give everyone, i.e. all the TA's, beta access to the course.
That will mean you'll be able to see the course materials a week in advance.
I think one of the best ways to give the most effective help to the students is if you do
the homeworks early in the week and then they will be in the forefront of your mind.
Also if you're doing the homeworks in advance you can submit them early to help us check
the auto grader operation.
We'll give you access to pivotal tracker to report and bugs or issues that arise.
Also if we've got critical errors such as the student Gitter chat is not working or
the auto graders are not working or anything then please escalate it by posting links to
the tracker ticket into the AV102 slack chat by typing @tansaku.
Which will alert me, Sam Joseph, which is where the buck stops here with making all
these things work :-)
Note that this is also an important part of working in a distributed team which is reporting
errors through an issues tracking system such as Pivotal Tracker and then including the
URL to that issue in digital communication like chat and email etc.
This is essential to ensure that everybody working on a given problem has access to all
the relevant information, and that we don't waste time or overwhelm people by giving the
same information over and over :-)